this night and what Tyler has done here
in Atlanta what do you think of you know
what he is such an amazing person always
extremely focused always very determined
and good things happen to good people
and if it's going to happen to anybody
this seems like the perfect night for
Whitney you know this seems like or not
like the night that she would love to be
here and take the stage and blow
everybody away you know loved her there
are great friends and she would be very
proud very what is going on is there
going to be the hologram will we see the
toy is that going to happen when how
where tell me something you know what we
have been we've been working it's been a
process we have to make sure she is
exactly what the fans you know want to
see and hear it's a it's a it's a wow
factor the Millennials have you know a
lot of them never saw and all you're
doing is just bringing back something
they love the music the legacy continues
with the music and we just decided to
give him something new and innovative
and that's a hologram alright last thing
this Robin book and all that stuff what
do you make of it hat what is the
family's reaction to this you know she
wants to write a book about who knows
what the book is about it's her story
you know is it fair you know to say she
can't write a book no it is it she had a
relationship with her so whatever it was
you know she's deciding to write a book
hey you know she can do that
[Music]
[Applause]